هذا تحرك من مئات التحركات التي شنتها
جمعيه صرخت المودعين منذ بدء الازمه ولا
اجابه حتى الان حول السؤال اين تبخرت
الودائع تحرك اليوم موجه ضد الافرع
الرئيسيه للمصارف التي يتهمها المودرون
بالتواطئ مع السلطه ما ادى الى خساره
ودائعهم
المصارف هنا اقفلت ابوابها تحسبا لتظاهرات
قد لا تخلو من العنف لكن التحرك حافظ على
سلميته مع اللجوء الى المفرقعات حينما
ورفع الشعارات على حواجز المصارف الحديديه
احيانا
نحن حقنا تعبنا وعمرنا بالغربه ما حنتركه
لا ياخذوا نصه ولا يغدوا ربعه
[موسيقى]
هذه التحركات تاتي بعد اسبوع قضائي حافل
وفود قضائيه اوروبيه استمعت الى وزير
المال وشقيق حاكم مصرف لبنان بتهم تسهيل
تحويل اموال على حساب حقوق الموضعين
المنهوبين اما محليا فكان الاتجاه معاكسا
طردت القاضيه اخذ عون التي كان لها جولات
في كشف قضايا فساد متعلقه بتحويل الاموال
ايش الموضوع فقط عند القضاء الموضوع هو
بمنظومه مقفله على ذاتها مترابطه الحلقات
ولا تسمح لنفسها بان تهوى هذا هو المكان
يلي اليوم نحن عنا السلطه متمسكه بكل
تاريخها اللي هو تاريخ لا يستقيم الا
بالعداله وبالتاكيد باعطاء الحقوق
سوى التحرك سهامه اليوم على رئيس حكومه
تصنيف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي احد اسرى
اثرياء العرب والمتهم بالاستفاده من قروض
الاسكان المخصصه لذوي الدخل المحدود
غنويات العربيه بيروت لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات